okay so black panther walk on the
forever is right around the corner and
we have some brand new TV spots and
trailers released as the marketing ramps
up throughout this video we're gonna be
going through it all to discuss the
hidden details things you missed and
also giving our theories on what's
happening in the film now the first of
these is the teaser title time and this
heavily features Riri Williams
grinding all my life
[Applause]
they came from the water
they had superhuman strength he's coming
for the surface world
that can't be good
[Music]
now is our time to strike
showed them
black panther wakanda forever really
PG-13 only in theaters November 11th get
tickets now now the trailer opens with
Sherry going to see Riri in one of the
wakandan labs at the end of the first
black panther we had to Charlie going to
a neighborhood in America and also the
UN originally my guess was that during
this time several programs and
initiatives of a Bright Young Minds were
created and Riri was brought in from the
US to study wakandan science however
there is another clip that kind of
debunks it which we'll talk about later
on in the video now in the teaser we see
her spraying what looks like a red
shoulder pad and this is a similar color
to the hot rod style that Tony used on
the Mark III I think she's gonna get
different suits similar to how Tony did
and we'll likely see her mark one Mark
II and even her Mark Ruffalo we also see
a spear and sheath and this will tie
back into the clip that we'll talk about
later on and we see her homemade suit
which we know from the trailers will
will be made out of car parts we've
never seen it assembled however here
it's completed along with a heart-shaped
reactor these heart shapes are something
that we see Echo throughout the film and
if you cast your mind back to the second
trailer then you may remember a scene in
which Nemo was painting he had a palette
made from a seashell and this had a
similar style heart shape in the middle
of it also we know from one of the clips
that neymo Nemo will be pronounced Namo
rather than Neymar and re-record the
earlier part several times as I kept
saying Nemo because for decades here I
pronounced it no more and then the
internet came along and told me I was
wrong so I had to relearn it but now
foggy is telling me I was right so my
brain is completely [ __ ] from
relearning it I'll probably still
pronounce it anymore a couple of times
in the video so yeah just in case you
want to know why this vid is more
terrible than our usual ones it's
because my brain's completely [ __ ] now
in the comics Riri made her own suit out
of parts at MIT which she seems to be
doing here the character comes from
Chicago and we also know we'll be
visiting the location based on the
license plate we see in the car scenes
we get a connection to this in the next
shot and a bridge with a well popping up
beside it the Tallow Canyon's attack and
later in the teaser we see the car
flipping over due to a wave hitting out
on this bridge Riri can also be seen
with her boots boosting up with her to
fly to a high altitude this is similar
to the shot in Infinity war in which
Tony should have to catch it with Peter
on ebony Moore's ship later on we see
her taking what I think is her first
flight as she skims along the water of
the river that the bridge scene is
probably at interestingly right after
this we see her helmet shot which is
similar to how it's presented with Tony
now one thing you might notice in her
DIY suit is that she has just a visor
that covers her eyes rather than a full
helmet therefore I think we're gonna see
her in several suits and probably get
more of a comic book accurate one the
visor wouldn't really provide this full
heads-up display with a face inside of
it so my guess is that it's just some
editing for the teaser other shots we've
seen the teaser having Baku attempting
to break his Club off the back of nemour
this instantly Shadows upon Him blocking
it and my man breaks it without even
making eye contact with him in the next
shot we see him Baku speaking with Nakia
to the left of them you can catch a
woman looking over a holographic
blueprint which looks like it might be a
ship the teaser ends with black panther
scaling down a giant vessel which I
think is one of the same of what this
woman is looking at I love the way that
the Black Panther moves during this and
I believe that this is shuri due to a
number of reasons we know that the
helmet is light with white dots on it
and these resemble the ones that she has
at the end of Black Panther and also at
the funeral there are other helmets that
appear in this teaser too and we see
someone reaching their hands how to do
helmets side by side though was so that
these two helmets might be teasers to
order the Black Panthers in the film I
think they're more likely being used as
a tribute to t'challa these are helmets
that the character has already worn in
the MCU and since the New Black Panther
is getting their own helmet I don't
think they'd be reusing the old ones one
of these helmets is also the one that
shuri carries at the funeral so the this
shot maybe her picking up to take it
there now another reason I think it
Sherry happens in this trailer when we
see nakira in her own armor this has a
helmet that grows around her face and
therefore I don't think she's going to
be taking up the mantle now the teaser
is also filled with shots of no more
attacking wakanda we see him flying
through the air and even get a close-up
shot of his winged feet the people of
wakanda are probably saying no more and
they might even ask him what is love
baby don't hurt me don't hurt me no more
that's a great teaser and I love the
action shot he had so bad
who we are
out of my dorm get out hey
I'm warning you do not take another step
toward me
see how they teach the children to treat
their guests
I like him I'm going back to the spear
shot we talked about earlier we have a
clip that shows Okoye and shuri going to
what I think is riri's dorm room again
this kind of debunks the idea that she
went to wakanda as part of a program I'm
guessing that we have a bridge scene
with a new suit and they see firsthand
the kind of text you can create from a
box of scraps from a box of scraps now
she could potentially discover a way to
stop no More's forces and this might be
why she's called to wakande I hope you
enjoying the video we'd love your 3000
if you click the thumbs up button and
also don't forget to hit subscribe for
our thoughts on the movie when it
releases anyway one of the best Clips
released in the movie has no more
meeting remander
stop right there
who are you and how did you get in here
[Music]
the air is
underwater
my mother told stories about a place
like this a protected land with people
that never had to leave
never have to change who they were
what reason do you have to rebuild your
secret to the world I am not a woman who
enjoys or repeating herself who aren't
you I have many names
my people call me
well my enemies call me no more
I'm all very much seems like he's
awakened in the new world and has
discovered how advanced wakanda is we
have seen clips and near the trailers
where he stood on the shore with a
burning house in front of him as a child
there were several things surrounding
the building that made a look Civil War
era so this is likely the first time
that he's seen a world like this this
also shows no more ages a lot slower
than regular people making it so that he
can be an adult in the 1930s like how he
was in the comics also raimonda is no
longer wearing her headpiece and I've
always thought that this represents her
crown this being off makes her look far
more vulnerable in how she typically
appears and we know that she's been to a
lot in the MCU she's lost her husband
her son possibly her kingdom and it's
been a lot on the character this clip
premiered on Jimmy Kimmel along with a
couple of other ones this includes one
of Akai Nikia when you left without
saying a word
it had
how you regret not being there with all
of you
it was not easy
he was
King and black panther to everyone
but to me
he was everything
so the way that Nikia goes on here it
makes me think that she distances
herself from wakanda after the events of
black panther she was in an Avengers
Infinity war and it's possible that she
left during this time there were some
leaks that I won't go into here that I
think could explain them but it's
possible that it ties into the
post-create scene which will link our
breakdown to at the end of the video
full disclosure I did have the post
credit scene spoiled for me along with
how they handled chichala's death
because I couldn't really help myself
however I do want to go into this movie
with some surprises so beyond that I
don't know what happens in the film
which is why this video probably won't
age that well and a kid talks about how
she knew the man rather than the king
and superhero and it's very much a meta
commentary on how the cast lost Chadwick
and what it means to them we knew the
actor but the cast in those involved
with the film very much knew the actual
man behind it all I love this sort of
fourth wall breaking scene and I feel
like the movie is gonna be one of those
rare instances where they can actually
use the death of someone to help provide
actual feelings of grief and loss
throughout the story I can't think of
another franchise where an actor has
died maybe used that passing to show the
Heartbreak that the cast actually went
to Paul Walker's death had some
commentary on in Fast and Furious Vegeta
brine still being alive in the universe
it didn't impact the story as much as
we're seeing here now the final clip I
want to talk about comes in the wake of
nemour's attack
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
so here we basically see the midst of
the tidal wave attack that's carried out
by no more in the comics during Avengers
versus X-men he ended up launching
something similar against wakanda and he
flooded the location before striking it
with his foot soldiers this will
obviously be a two-fold attack and I
think there might even be a third layer
added to it the first part is that
people obviously struggle in water so
flooding a location would make it far
more difficult for people to fight back
the second is that the Tallow canyons
are now able to fight there and they're
not out there depth Judah being on land
not pun by the way well it was a pun I
think the third part of this attack will
come from the air with the more flying
around the city and striking I love how
my man here is just continuing his
business completely oblivious to the
whole thing and the Dora melange put
earbuds in in order to protect their
ears from the explosives later on the
water you see some of the Tallow Canyons
just chilling like it's some
synchronized swimming up before they're
blasted in the air shuri arrives in a
new type of ship which we know no more
attacks from the other teasers this has
wings added to it now that almost
operate like a dragonfly to put it in a
hover mode I'm surprised chewy is
actually in this that's the first film
showed she can control vehicles from the
lab you might also know it's actually as
a co-pilot and I'm guessing they had to
be their own person to pull people out
of the water we see some talo Canyons
jumping out and you may notice they have
blue skin whereas no more doesn't they
also wear masks when on the surface and
a more can breathe oxygen because in the
comics he's a mutant like a mutation
hoping they bring this into the film too
and we can slowly slowly slowly crawl
towards the X-Men movie in 2030 or
whatever now you also see the strength
difference between them as imbaku
manages to knock one out with his Club
Razzie the trailer sure breaking off
their moles back he's covered in
vibranium so he can completely outclass
the rest and it's a great little clip
anyway that ends the video and obviously
I'd love to hear your thoughts on the
new spots and teasers wearing any
competition right now and giving away
three copies of top gun Maverick on the
15th of November and all you have to do
to be on the chance of winning is like
the video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the TV spots
you pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now so
that's you message me on Twitter at
heavy spoilers if you want something
else to watch make sure you check out
our Brighton of the Ant-Man and the WASP
Quantum Mania trailer which will be
linked on screen right now lots of
things going on with it and will love to
see over there you son of a [ __ ] I know
you're in see that mate come on take
that trap bye